yeah i guess like did you ever watch
like the american ports of like japanese
tv shows
oh in america no i got uh i was able to
watch
fuji tv when i was growing up in japan
so
it was just in japanese so i never
really thought anything so you never
watched like the
the the spin-off of like silent library
with like all the wwe players
wait what what [ __ ] you okay
so silent okay i thought everyone knew
this one so silent library is based
inside of like a like a proper like
public library
and they would pull out of a hat to do
like a bunch of like punishment games
that are like either really painful or
like really loud or like you know get
like a reaction at them but because
they're in a public library
they have to be really quiet while doing
all of it so i remember there was one
where there was like
one of the comedians like gets like
[ __ ] slapped in the face by like
a sumo wrestler and he can't make a
sound like he can't make us
like a reaction and obviously the other
comedians can't laugh how did they get
the sumo in the let's see
the library to slap someone just come in
the library slap this dude
but then i guess like american tv i
forgot which station it was but american
tv took that
and replaced the comedians with
wrestlers
from the wwe so they were like
it was actually really funny because
these wrestlers would be in a public
library
[ __ ] doing like german suplexes to
one another
like it's a [ __ ] full on but like all
really silently
and it was still a library like this
yeah it was like a proper library
it must be fake yeah but still it was
like just seeing like all these
[ __ ] massive six foot brick [ __ ]
houses doing german suplexes to one
another quietly as possible
unfortunately most british tv shows
don't get good adaptations in the us not
really
no because british humor is weird yeah i
feel like the only good adaptation i've
seen
is the office yeah i i would like hazard
to call that an adaptation because it's
nothing like the british office
they like it was one of the few examples
where they took what
worked about the office and did their
own version it's completely different
but it works
in a different way yeah they still paid
homage to it right like yeah the first
season is very similar to
the actual office yeah first season's
very hard to watch yeah exactly
that's what we like that's what we like
i totally get it i
absolutely understand but oh my god i
just skip right past it every single
time i can't i'm so itchy when i watch
it
i love cringe humor i love cringy don't
get me started about the american
version of the in-betweeners that is
probably like a lot of people like to
forget that it exists but it's something
that exists i i didn't even know it
existed
to be honest you know the in-between no
i don't really popular
tv show that came out i think when we
were in gantt university i was in like
no i was i was actually in secondary
school then i started oh it finished
right
i was the same age as the characters in
the in-betweeners
as it was airing which is why it was
[ __ ] massive yeah it was it was huge
in the uk
especially just four students um just
being like pretty
accurate students and just messing up
life situations
yeah and uh you know trying to like get
girls and stuff and being [ __ ] awful
i think that's just really cringe humor
the closest way i can describe it is
like it's
american pie kind of but like everything
goes wrong
yeah everything's scripted though yeah
it's like a drama it's a scripted like
it's a sitcom
so it's kind of like an american pie
sitcom but just with british humor where
you see these
like four no yeah four misfits just try
to get laid
and it no matter what they do it always
goes wrong
right right and they just cause awful
situations like everything
it sounds amazing yeah the british
version is [ __ ] horrible yeah yeah
yeah
i never knew about the american version
and to be honest
it's so bad it's so bad